[Music]
hey you guys and thanks for tuning in to
ET live I'm Katie Krauss and Diego
Boneta is here thank you for being here
this morning
thank you for having me we're very
excited about this new series that
you're doing with Telemundo Luis Miguel
was i okay with that I've been working
on my accent you guys um let's get right
into it and if you guys are tuning in
make sure that you send me your fan
questions for Diego we are gonna get to
them but tell me about what excited you
about this project and how familiar you
are with Luis Miguel's life going into
it Wow a lot of things excited me about
this project first off he was my hero
growing up so when I found out that Mark
Burnett was behind this yeah you knows
it was amazing cuz Mark and I worked
together a couple years ago doing a show
called the Duff Keepers which we shot in
Malta and we became close friends there
and it was I was I was intrigued at
first to know totally how they wanted to
execute this sure right and when I heard
that they wanted to go in the vibe of
like Ray and walk the line and really
you know do it edgy but in a in a cool
way and you know the music and also the
personal life and all that it was I was
I was in I was pumped as a fan of his
how much pressure did you feel to get it
right all the pressure yeah yeah big
time yeah because yeah he's for us he's
his voice is unbelievable
he has a really really amazing voice I
was yes I had to sing everything there's
there's no reference of him in the whole
show all the pictures all the album
covers all the songs everything was me
so it was I asked mark I was like when
you guys want to shoot this just because
of the prep you know I've never had to
prep for a character like like this ever
you know from a physical the angle vocal
and then acting who's a year of only
prep only prep
yeah this is the the craziest part of
that I mean were you doing like physical
type transformation for this what did
what went into that everything I had to
tan a lot yeah which was like spray tan
or like tanning bed tanning bed and
tanning like naturally tanning a lot
because the guy was very tan yeah I know
it sounds silly but it was part of the
thing yeah he also had this this gap in
his teeth which was you know he was very
famous for that gap and Manuel after all
these prosthetics and stuff and nothing
really worked yeah I looked like Austin
Powers I was like guys there has to be
something that works I mean you see all
these movies with all these CGI effects
I mean come on it's a tooth cut so I
went to my orthodontist they were
literally about to actually do the gap
and and she doesn't weigh well let's
just try one last thing and you know
what they glue braces with yes yeah so
they they they put that but instead of
it being white it was black and they and
they yeah it was permanent for the for
the for the duration of the shoot so I
had that for like a year this is a gap
he would go out after your unsettled day
and you would still have it yeah yeah
which was weird cuz once I finished the
gig and I went back to Diego it was I
didn't recognize the person I was seeing
in the mirror you know you think they
colored my hair the tanning I dropped
like 25 pounds that's just on the
physical side of things and then the the
vocal side of things was another crazy
challenge and then the acting too were
you taking voice lessons cuz you can
sing I mean you did Rock of Ages and you
put out albums see you how to really
work with a vocal coach yes but the
thing yeah because I had to sound like
someone else in Rock of Ages I didn't
have to sound like like Steve Perry when
I sung don't stop believin it was me
singing right here it was you have to
sing his songs in the same key as lose
me gouge them they're very very high
yeah is like a Bruno Mars or like a
Freddie Mercury register very high voice
tenor and you have to sound like him and
that's where it was it was really
difficult because none of us neither my
vocal coach the producer nor myself had
ever done this before so it was an
experiment of let's see how close we can
get
yeah so let's focus on the vibrato let's
change your vibrato to his vibrato and
pronounce vowels the way he does and
consonants and really really going for
the smallest of details which was which
is very obsessive it was we were going
for I mean in every single song we did
like maybe 15 or 16 songs and each song
was was really really tough I mean all
of them had at least one hi-c which is a
very high note with me but she's belting
it was it was hard yeah I mean he's it's
like what this man can do vocally it's
like watching Michael Phelps you know
you just don't understand how it's how
it's even possible how it's human you
said that you lost 25 pounds for this
yeah were you just eating healthier were
you working out walk me through that
both I was was I was eating healthier I
was uh went from doing more calisthenics
stuff instead of weights yeah and yeah I
mean it was yeah but that was I feel the
easiest out of everything believe yeah
yeah I mean the local side of things was
not the acting side of things things
really hard to because there's there's
no reference to this man you know he's
done maybe ten ten interviews you know
there's not a lot of interviews but also
I'm not playing the guy in front of the
cameras I'm playing the guy behind the
cameras and there's no reference to that
so it was kind of creating that with the
information that I had being able to sit
down with Luiz Miguel and you know just
spend time with him which was very
helpful but also you know just kind of
building that character from from
nothing and that was probably the most
difficult challenge yeah I can't imagine
Burkburnett said that
you and Luis Miguel met that it was
instant chemistry instant friendship
walk me through what happened in that
first conversation how'd you win him
over
we're just I mean I I showed him the
video of me singing his song when I was
12 years old and I said listen man III
was I'm sorry I butchered this song I
was 12 years old I've my voice was
changes Watchi were laughing and just I
mean we have a lot of things in common
you know we both started at a very young
age we have a lot of friends in common
and I mean I just know we hit it off
great yeah it was there anything that he
said you have to get this right he
didn't say one thing specifically but he
did look at me and at the end or like
halfway through the dinner he just
looked at me and he was like man like
this is a big challenge for you this is
this is this is tough yeah because he
was you know you're you're doing it
everything you know you know so I was
like yeah yeah it's tough yeah but being
being being able to to have him as a
partner in crime throughout this process
was really amazing because many times
you you know you get projects like this
but the person who playing already died
or you know it's you know and it was
really cool to count with that were
there times throughout production and
filming that you were calling him on the
phone or maybe texting with him and
asking for advice or asking how he would
want something done yeah because the I
think the best part of this whole thing
was having a year to prep yeah and once
we started shooting I had already become
this guy you know so I never felt the
necessity to call him or ask him
something I I didn't do it cuz I because
I didn't want it I just I just didn't I
mean we were we were all there we were
we were in it and and he helped me get
there you know
what surprised you the most during that
prep about his life
about him what he's gone through what I
mean the fact that after all that he's
gone through he's still the man and the
artist that he is like I said I already
admired him a lot as an artist yeah but
after playing him and being him for a
year
I now admire him as a person and I hope
that's what happens to people that watch
this yeah
whether they know of him or not right
cuz it's it's a very you know universal
theme sure you know there's a lot of
I've heard that there's a lot of
references to his love life yeah in it
are we gonna see his relationship with
Mariah Carey play out at all oh this
smirk right here not in this season so
there's gonna be a season two maybe is
that news I mean we'll see we'll see
we'll see we'll see but what I can't say
is that his the the women in his life
mm-hmm all play a very important role
starting from his mom which is probably
the most yeah
important to his first girlfriend
mariana played by Paulina Davila it was
super super I mean there it's they're
there they're there for a very specific
reason and they're all I mean they all
killed it like really the the cast in
this in this show is unbelievable for
Oscar cañada who's an unbelievable
Spanish actor who plays my dad cuz it's
really a lot of a father-son story if
you watched Amedeo it's similar to
Mozart and Salieri you know that kind of
like dynamic do you feel like you have a
friendship with Luis Miguel no yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah it's it's
it's he's he's he's really cool a he's
he's really funny he has a great sense
of humor that's surprising because he is
so reserved and we
know a lot about him so he like that's a
fun little he's very he has a great
sense yeah we're gonna take some fan
questions and if you guys are just
tuning in make sure that you're sending
them here but at TN from facebook says
what was it like shifting gears to do a
big production in all Spanish that's a
great question at the end how are you it
was it was it was a big challenge it was
my first time in ten years doing
anything in Spanish and and doing
anything in Latin America and it was a
blast the first thing that I really
wanted to do was train with a with a
with a with a Spanish speaking vocal
coach to really just switch gears to
just Spanish because this past decade
I've only done stuff in English while
ages scream queens and yeah and and this
is all Spanish and Italian as well so I
started reading a lot in Spanish
watching movies in Spanish reading plays
in Spanish training with this amazing
coach and and really you know I think
that someone that killed this was our
director Beto Humberto in Xhosa who
directed all 13 episodes just something
that's not common because in TV you have
a different director come in every every
other episode yeah so it really feels
like a 13 hour movie and he was truly a
partner in crime in this whole process
and and he created a very specific world
and and and you can see it play out in
all 13 episodes with it you know it's
the creative continuity is is spot-on
thanks to this man have you seen all the
episodes already I've seen some of them
some of them yeah okay has Luis seen him
I don't know I don't know yet okay so
you don't know what he thinks of all of
it how it all came together
I played him a couple of scenes when we
when I redid
one a very famous music video that that
that he did and he took my phone and he
zoomed in he goes like that's that's me
like that that's that's me and seeing
that that reaction was probably I mean I
was I was I was upset you know he was he
was he was really really pumped and I
mean that meant the world to me did you
get all the mannerisms down yeah yeah
yeah and it was it's yeah cuz it I
claimed and it's like Spanish five six
years and the mannerisms change
throughout the years and I think the
biggest challenge was that we were
shooting out of continuity all 13
episodes so on any given day I could
have a scene from the pilot from episode
13 from episode 5 and from episode 8 and
and it's it's it's it's a five six-year
window so going from being seventeen to
being you know 20 to being 18 to being
22 and and changing the the mannerisms
that go with each different stage of his
life you know that's that I mean pretty
gnarly that you were able to keep track
of that and then which I had all these
all these all these uh like how do you
call it tips to help me through three
ready notes oh yeah I had pages and
pages and pages and pages of notes every
day yeah that's what about the hair and
makeup process how long did that take on
a daily maintenance depends on the the
age I was playing him but around two
hours some horrible wasn't horrible okay
no the once we got the tooth gap down
that was it was that was the most
difficult part believe it or not which
is I did it's sink yeah I get I get why
changing gears a little bit I have to
say congratulations because you've
joined the untitled Terminator reboot
very excited I'm thrilled yeah what did
you do when you got that call
well I yelled celebrate I was like
because it was it was a crazy process
and I was it was a project that I was
really excited about and it's tough
because you can never get your hopes up
right and then when it when it happened
I would I still can't believe it I mean
just the fact you have to be able to
work with someone James Cameron and Tim
Miller who's in I mean it's it's it's
it's unbelievable sure I'm really really
excited
well we're excited for you you said it
was a crazy process what was the
audition process for that like well I I
sent a tape first while I was shooting
Louise Miguel it's just funny because
the cast of it was like wait what
happened yeah of course yeah
tooth gap I was blond I was super tan
and the cast was like Diego what did you
do I'm like Mindy I'm so sorry I'm
playing this guy I swear to God okay and
then the met met with Tim who's nicest
guy ever really such an amazing guy yeah
and I'm so talented and and we hit it
off and then right after Louise MeeGo
rapped at the hop on a plane and go to
Dublin for the weekend to do the screen
test there with Mackenzie Davis and
another cast mates no there no okay
no no he was not there it was crazy guys
I was sick I had a bad sinus infection
yeah they had a drip div' like hours
before I left
hop on a plane I was there for two days
just flew to Dublin from LA to Dublin
for a weekend yeah got back and it was
after a year of shooting Luiz Miguel it
was it was it was really really really
really intense so when when I got the
call for my team letting me know that I
bet I got I was that was I mean yeah
yeah were you a fan of the original
Terminator movie
of course yeah how many times have you
seen them wolf well I had to re-watch
them again now and it's it's amazing how
they hold up yeah timeless maleeh
unbelievable I think some of the best
action movies of all time if not the
best have you been able to read the
script yeah I mean there's a lot
everything is very under wraps right now
yeah
yes yes but they're so you've read the
whole thing all the way through though
yeah what can you tell us about your
character is he a good guy is he a
villain I I really can't say okay but
what I can't say is that I'm I'm really
excited really really really excited to
be a part of this and and I can't wait
to start shooting
have you met Arnold at all no no no you
don't know anything about like his
health right now hidden recent scare
okay no but I hope he's easy don't
better yeah how do you think that the
reboot will differ from the original
movies maybe you can answer that I think
that's that's that's a question for Tim
what I think is amazing about this one
is that is that the team that James
Cameron and Tim Miller may I mean it's
it's it's a great marriage
I mean Deadpool was one of my favorite
movies last year oh good so good and
James Cameron is James Cameron yeah and
just from doing that that screen test
with with Tim and talking to him he
knows exactly what he wants and when
you're working with a with a director
that just has that so clear you just it
just makes you trust them so much more
he knows exactly what what he wants and
I think that I mean it's I'm pumped I
mean I'm really really really excited
are you gonna have to do any physical
changes or
informations of any kind no no I'm gonna
have to keep training nothing crazy
okay so now gap-toothed no gap sir
no gap tooth no no Danny no tan no no
please yeah no more tanning no no no
yeah okay and then just kind of changing
gears a little bit you're very much a
private guy for being so well-known kind
of like Luis Miguel is that intentional
we never hear about you in the news
causing trouble
linked to anyone I don't think it's
intentional I I do like keeping my
private life private yeah I'm also not
someone to not do something because
there's press sure like for example when
we were shooting Rock of Ages and I was
we're all staying in the same buildings
Tom Cruise was there and and was a brand
and Alec and I mean there's a lot of
paparazzi's outside because of them no
because of me I still go to the beach
you know I'm not I'm not gonna not live
my life because of that yeah but I I
like to to keep press about work and if
something personal does come out you
know it's just I just like to keep it
yeah yeah there was a rumor last year
that you were dating Camila Kibeho what
is that about
oh he's drinking the water no yeah we we
met last year she's half Mexican half
Cuban I'm I was born in in Mexico City
and I think she's really really talented
yeah and she's crushing the game and I I
just love the fact that you know she's
latina and she's and she's killing it
and she's she's a friend she's a friend
yeah there we go he's got the answers I
love that and before we wrap up I guess
we should take a few more fan questions
but what do you want people to take away
after they watch Luis Miguel
I mean to obviously have fun yeah enjoy
because it is a very fun show it has
kind of like that wolf of wallstreet
craziness with with pairing up with some
really intense drama for the for the
people that you know that don't know of
him too yeah I'd love for them to watch
the show because and see what they think
is I think there's a lot of similarities
to you know big stars like Michael
Jackson Elvis Presley or Frank Sinatra
and some you know things are a timeless
it's beautifully shot and for people
that do know him like I said I think
having that personal admiration of this
of this you know who this guy is similar
to like when you watch Trey with Jamie
Foxx in the first time you're like wow
like he went through all this and he's
still ray yeah and I feel though like
Jamie became ray or that's how I felt
watching them 100% it sounds like that's
what's gonna happen with this series
yeah and it's it's it's it's funny
because I into Jamie before doing this
and I said listen man I mean what you
did with Ray was unbelievable I just got
a show with Mark cuz he did the show
Shazaam with Mark Burnett and I'm not
sure if you know this Latin singer but
Louise migos yes of course I know Lizzy
big oh my god that guy is crazy pipes
and he dated Mariah Oh yet excuse me I
was like what can I do
I mean give me a Tico's man just
whenever there's a reference and it's a
scene with the reference if he breathes
in a minute 222 mm-hmm
copy everything I mean be obsessive
about making it I mean so if they
watched both together yeah they can't
tell the difference and that was
probably the best piece of advice and
Oscar I now that also told me the same
thing I lost but please my dad he did a
movie in Spain where he played the
biggest flamenco singer of all time and
he also did a movie buck and theme plus
was the biggest Mexican comic of all
time and he also told me the same exact
thing and that was that was really
really helpful all right we're gonna
take two more fan questions and we're
gonna wrap up so Annie says scream
queens with my favorite show there have
been rumors recently that Lea Michele Oh
God is illiterate can you set the
records hey I should have read that
beforehand
I guess there's rumors that way Michelle
really no but obviously she's reading
the script no that's that's that's false
that's 100% false no Lia is not no all
right Alexis from facebook says love
doing Rock of Ages do you keep in touch
with Tom Cruise or Julianne Hough at all
Thank You Tori great movie thank you
thank you thank you so much that was my
first movie and that's still I mean I
think the best learning experience of my
life yeah and best summer of my life
Miami 21 years old
summer South Beach I'll tell you stories
later Tommy is the man tom is really
he's the most he's the hardest-working
most humble down-to-earth man I know we
still keep in touch and I mean he's he's
he's unbelievable I he's really awesome
Julian
Alec yeah we all do keep in touch and
every time we see each other it's it's
great because we all had a blast
shooting that movie it was so much fun
did Tom give you any advice going into
this no but I I told him I was I was
doing this cuz mark is also friends with
with Tom and and and I said hey we're
all we're all working together and we do
keep in touch you know in many ways I
see him as a mentor cuz you know he it
was really nice of him cuz when I did
Rock of Ages I was that was my first
movie and he did like he took me under
his wing he was like you're like shadow
me on said and like you know you should
you should learn how to do things the
right way and and and I never had anyone
in my life or in my career do that with
me except Tom and Tom is yeah the
biggest movie star in the world
that's why though cuz he's so nice but
that's why yeah and that's why that's
what I tell everyone you know he's
really such a nice guy and in so
talented and very hard-working that's
that's that's
he's so hard-working well thank you so
much for being here really fast will you
just let them know where they can tune
in on April 22nd of course April 22nd if
you are watching in the US you
watch it in Telemundo at 9/8 central and
if you're watching from Latin America
Spain you can watch it on Netflix same
time Sunday 22nd
I think they pushed the hour because of
the Mexican presidential debate so it's
gonna be at 9:00 that was because of the
fans david much doughnuts which is
amazing well I think was actually the
Mexican government that requested it
late there was so much buzz around it
and this is the first Mexican
presidential debate for the elections
which are in July yeah they're like at
the same time move it an hour which is
just crazy it's gonna be a big deal
though I mean that's huge yeah so we
think season two then is looking good
hopefully hopefully we watch it guys yes
thank you so much thank you guys for
watching and make sure that you keep up
with Diego and social media make sure
that you like e t--'s Facebook page
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
have a great weekend
it's at Diego not Diego Boneta it's at
Diego guys thank you so much take care
thank you
always hey guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you